cuando tenía unos 8 años tuve una
profesora que impacto mi vida y hoy
quiero dedicar esta charla ted a la
memoria de la licenciada iturralde no no
no ya no se ha muerto ya está bien ella
está muy bien tranquilos pero tenía una
memoria impresionante se acordaba de
todo no se le escapaba
y ella era amiga de profe me dicen yo
soy la licenciada iturralde se demora
más pero se expone menos nos decía y me
tenía una bronca con decirles que ya
llegaba con los exámenes y decía señor
canal días tiene cero y lo disfrutaba y
todo
[Música]
profe pero si aún no hemos presentado el
examen
cuestión de quién por cuestión de tiempo
tenga y me tenía bronca no porque yo
fuera un patán un malcriado ni porque
fuera mal estudiante si yo era los que
me sentaban de la segunda o tercera fila
que ustedes saben que hay jerarquías no
en la primera fila se sientan los
estudiosos en la segunda para atrás los
que quieren pasar más desapercibidos y
atrás la delincuencia pura del salón yo
me sentaba entre la segunda y tercera
fila ósea
pero la licenciada iturralde
le molestaba mucho que a mí me gustara
reír y hacer reír porque ella
consideraba o asociaba como muchas
personas asociaba la risa con falta de
respeto con falta de inteligencia con
falta de atención o con falta de control
y estoy asociar la risa con cosas
negativas es más común de lo que
pensamos
hay gente que no le gusta que otras
personas se rían e incluso a todos nos
ha pasado que estamos en una carcajada
con alguien y hay el que dice adiós
nomás ya nomás ay me he reído tanto que
algo malo me va pas cierto porque
asociamos la risa con cosas malas y esto
es algo muy común hay gente que incluso
dice la vida mover su juego la vida no
es una broma fin cierto hay gente que
dice eso pero se equivocan porque la
vida si es un juego y como en un juego
cuando eras niño y jugaba en el parque y
te caías a veces la vida duele y te caes
y te lastimas pero cuando eras niño te
caías te levantabas que suma más lloraba
si era necesario y volvía a entrar
porque sabías que el juego no se había
terminado la vida es igual y también se
equivocan aquellos que dicen que la vida
no es una broma porque la vida es una
broma y el querría el último puedo
entender el chiste
un día la licenciada actoral de me
sentenció de por vida esta profesora era
más era bien ácida era miel era tan
ácida que ella se chupaba un limón pero
era el limón el que hacía caras y
escupía las pepas pero para mí era
ciudad y un día ella se voltea y me dice
escuchen bien señor harold steven días
usted con esos chistecitos no va a
llegar a ningún lado en la vida no va a
ser nadie
y se lo firmo
y me sentenció
y así fue como una persona a la que yo
respetaba admiraba a una persona con
autoridad sobre mí una persona a la que
yo consideraba más inteligente y capaz
que yo me sentenció a ser un fracasado
de por vida
como crecí me sentía
me sentí como seguramente te has sentido
tú cuando alguien a quien aprecia so a
quien admiras te descalifica yo sentí
que me habían robado parte de mi
identidad porque para mí el humor es un
regalo que dios me dio para agitar la
conciencia yo estoy seguro que nací para
esto yo estoy convencido seguro de que
yo nací para hacer reír porque esto es
tan así que cuando mi mamá le dijo a mi
papá estoy embarazada él dijo esto tiene
que ser un chiste
los años pasaron y me costó trabajo
volver a tomar confianza pero hoy que
soy comediante que trabajo en televisión
en radio en cine hoy que doy con mi
conferencias combinando la capacitación
con la comedia y la neurociencia estoy
convencidísimo estoy convencido de que
el humor es una herramienta
impresionante para entender para superar
los momentos difíciles de la vida y para
disfrutarla es una herramienta que nos
ayuda a disfrutar de las cosas que
tenemos pero también de asumir nuestras
pérdidas como un amigo me dice el otro
día
harold desde que se fue mi ex novia no
puedo dormir no estoy tranquilo no estoy
no estoy en paz no tengo paz le digo que
la amaba mucho no es que yo quede de
garante de un crédito que sacó de ella y
trances
definitivamente el humor es una
herramienta impresionante una
herramienta que nos ayuda a darle
sentido a las cosas y en un mundo en el
que pasan tantas cosas sin sentido no
podemos permitir que nos roben el
sentido del humor no podemos permitir
que nos lo quiten porque el humor es un
superpoder pero es un poder distinto a
los tradicionales a los que vemos en
televisión o en cine mira en los años 70
le hacen una entrevista a roberto gómez
bolaños el gran chespirito uno de los
comediantes más reconocidos más
importantes en el mundo sus personajes
como el chavo del ocho o el chapulín han
sido traducidos a más de 60 idiomas han
sido adaptados a dibujos animados en fin
y le hacen una entrevista en argentina
los años 60 en los años 70 y le dice el
entrevistador chespirito que eran
argentinas chacrita y que pensamos de
los grandes superhéroes como por ejemplo
superman dicho espíritu dice superman
superman no es ningún superhéroe como
les sí que me superhéroes es el más
famoso del mundo
superman no es ningún superhéroe por qué
superman sabe que si se enfrenta a los
bandidos él es todo poderoso y si le
disparan por las balas le rebotan en el
pecho eso no tiene nada de heroico pero
el chapulín colorado' que se enfrenta a
los bandidos sin superpoderes y tiene
razón el chapulín no tiene poderes pero
tú me vas a decir tiene las pastillas de
chiquitolina bueno así pero analicemos
el chapulín es chaparro y su poder es
volverse aún más chaparro eso no es un
poder
eso no sirve para nada y te lo digo con
autoridad porque yo soy chaparro yo soy
patucho yo soy tan patucho que la foto
de las células algo el cuerpo entero
sin embargo el chapulín se enfrente a
los bandidos como lo harías superman el
chapulín no tiene super fuerza ni super
velocidad no tiene armas sofisticadas
tiene un chipote chillón es débil
efe se muere de miedo es torpe sin
embargo se enfrenta a los bandidos como
lo haría superman y los vence porque
tiene corazón de superhéroe actitud de
superhéroe y el super poder del humor un
poder que nos inspira y nos motiva a
reconocer nuestras debilidades a
reconocer nuestros derrotas a reconocer
nuestros miedos a aceptarlos y a ser
valientes pero valientes en el sentido
en el que decía este otro gran hombre ex
presidente de sudáfrica y premio nobel
de la paz un luchador incansable en
contra del racismo
nelson mandela quien dijo
el valor no es la ausencia del miedo
sino es aprender a superar lo valiente
no es el que no tiene miedo sino el que
lo conquista así es definitivamente así
es y ya que el miedo nos va a acompañar
en muchas etapas en muchos momentos de
la vida es mejor que aprendamos a
convivir con ella a superarlo no te
parece hay veces que te vas a sentir
feliz y asustado al mismo tiempo a mí me
pasó por ejemplo cuando fui a conocer
por primera vez a mis suegros y a
confesarles a ellos y a mis cuñados que
su princesita y yo estábamos embarazados
y viéndolos a conocer ella tenía mes y
medio de embarazo pero yo ya estaba
pariendo del susto
pero cuando te empiezas a reír
el miedo deja de tener poder sobre ti
esto es maravilloso
mira tú te empiezas a reír y el miedo
inmediatamente empieza a perder poder es
como cuando asustas a alguien
cuando cae la risa el miedo deja de
tener poder y algo similar sucede con el
dolor mira el dolor y el humor no son
contrarios
de hecho la comedia se basa en la
realidad y la realidad a veces es muy
dura sin embargo
humor la risa nos hace más fuertes y nos
ayuda a superar con esta fortaleza el
dolor y esto lo reafirma la neurociencia
y la neurociencia nos dice que el humor
el humor la risa es excelente para
nuestra salud física y emocional que la
risa mejora nuestra creatividad que la
risa nos ayuda a cooperar mejor entre
personas que la risa estimula algunas
áreas de nuestro cerebro algunas
dedicadas a situaciones y procesos muy
complejos como es el enfoque como es la
toma de decisiones cómo es la atención
dirigida es impresionante es
impresionante la risa estimula el área
del placer y la recompensa instantánea
lo que nos hace sentir bien genera
dopamina endorfinas entre otros
neurotransmisores y hormonas que no
solamente nos hacen sentir bien que
reducen el dolor que nos hacen sentir
también más motivados y más seguros
la risa controla la presión alta
arterial evita evita en un porcentaje
impresionante el riesgo de ataque
cardíaco y mucho más
pero sobre todo sobre todo la risa nos
ayuda
a disfrutar de los procesos y no solo
del final porque hay veces no sé si te
has dado cuenta que estamos tan
enfocados en alcanzar una meta en
alcanzar un objetivo que dejamos de
disfrutar de las cosas diarias y dices
ya seré feliz ya reiré cuando cuando
termine la carrera cuando tenga el
título cuando compre el carro cuando
compre la casa cuando consiga y esté con
la persona que amo y empezamos a
postergar y postergar la felicidad y si
vivimos postergando la felicidad hasta
obtener las metas vamos a pasar la mayor
parte del tiempo tristes
cierto o amargados por eso es que es
importante vivir desde ya y por eso
estoy convencido de que la vida es una
broma y él querría el último chiste
la risa además nos ayuda a mejorar
nuestra actitud y esto es muy importante
porque se se han dado cuenta que la
actitud es como los besos apasionados
igualita la actitud es como los besos
apasionados lo que pasa arriba se siente
abajo de igual manera lo que pasa aquí
arriba en tu cabeza se siente y se
manifiesta en todo tu cuerpo en todo tu
ser
la risa también nos ayuda a redefinir
nuestro enfoque el humor redefine
nuestro enfoque nos ayuda a plantearnos
y esto es importantísimo porque el
enfoque nos acerca o nos aleja de
nuestros objetivos como el que dice
doctor doctor quiero bajar de peso pero
todo el tiempo pienso en comida y esto
le pasa muy a menudo lo cierto que es
muy importante la risa pero sobre todo
la risa también nos ayuda a cuestionar
el poder y las injusticias lo que se
hace en memes lo que se hace en parodias
y yo tengo algunas anécdotas al respecto
mira una vez estaba entrevistando a un
ex presidente del ecuador no uno que
habla así y le digo él me dice yo estaba
con otros personajes que interpreto y él
me dice y conmigo estaba muy mejor
conmigo el pueblo quattor ya no podía
dormir tranquilo conmigo dormían como un
bebé y el higo tiene razón con usted
dormíamos como un bebé despertándonos a
llorar cada dos horas porque estábamos
con hambre o hecho
el papá
el humor es una herramienta poderosa
para cuestionar la realidad pero es una
herramienta tan poderosa que a veces
también es utilizado como un arma masiva
como un arma para construir la imagen de
alguien o para denigrar y destruir la
imagen de alguien para construir o para
destruir para destruir personas para
atacar grupos también se puede utilizar
de esa manera eso sí si el humor
destruye construye depende de quien
empuña la herramienta pero también de
quienes reaccionamos ante el humor y
ante el chiste y de cómo lo hacemos es
una responsabilidad compartida hay
muchas cosas que podríamos decir del
humor pero definitivamente la
característica que más me gusta es como
el humor nos ayuda a conectar con otras
personas aún en momentos de tristeza y
de dolor y esto es impresionante lo sé
porque porque igual que tú he vivido
momentos de tristeza momentos de dolor
pero también porque he tenido la
oportunidad de ser parte de algunas
organizaciones sociales sobre todo
trabajando con personas con cáncer y de
acompañarlos incluso en el momento de su
partida te puedes imaginar un momento
más inadecuado para hacer un chiste que
ese
yo recuerdo con mucho amor a todos mis
amigos que partieron pero hoy pienso en
una nena de 16 años con cáncer terminal
que cuando los doctores le dijeron que
no había nada más que hacer cuando ella
sabía que llegó el momento de irse
asustada ella lógicamente acostada en su
cama rodeada de su mamá a un par de
familiares ella me voltea y me dice
cuentan un chiste
si normalmente cuando alguien te dice a
quemarropa cuéntame un chiste
uno no sabe qué decir peor en ese
momento que yo tenía el corazón arrugado
y un nudo en la garganta de despedir a
mi amiga y le digo un chiste para qué y
me dice porque el humor porque la risa
alivia el alma
le digo sí y además es buenísimo para la
salud y ella arrancó a reír soltó una
carcajada que nos contagió a todos y
todos empezamos a reír ya reír y a reír
ya reír y a reír y mágicamente cambió la
atmósfera del lugar todavía había dolor
todavía había miedo pero ahora también
había paz ahora también había esperanza
así la recuerdo
así la recuerdo a ella riéndose a
carcajadas de la misma muerte y así
quiero vivir yo riendo y haciendo reír
disfrutando del viaje bromeando con
quienes me encuentro en el camino en la
vida mirando a la cara al dolor mirando
la cara a las inseguridades burlando me
de ellas festejando los triunfos pero
también burlando me de mis fracasos como
decía charles chaplin la vida es una
obra de teatro que no permite ensayos
así que ríe canta baila llora vive
intensamente antes de que el telón baje
y la obra termine sin aplausos al fin y
al cabo la vida es una broma y el que
ría el último muchas gracias
[Aplausos]